some people in there on the red carpet I
was just like winning an award doesn't
mean we write these songs in like 40
minutes and then we just send them to
somebody and then we never really refer
back to them ever again I'm a bad actor
I realize now that I've had to try and
make music videos need motivation watch
a top 10 of a belief nation what's up at
7 my one word is believe and I believe
in you I believe you have an amazing
gift inside you that I want to see
explode out onto the world so let's get
your motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a sack and chew on
today's lessons from a woman who went
from starting her career in a local acid
jazz band in Adelaide Australia and
having her boyfriend died in a car
accident to have in a mainstream music
career with nine Grammy Awards and
multiple number-one hit songs she see up
and here's my take on her top 10 rules
of success enjoy
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one define success for yourself I
don't care if I we know no I don't care
but it's also like it's I mean it's nice
but it's fully it's fully whatever man
you know I was saying to some people in
there on the red carpet I was just like
winning an award doesn't mean you know
like not not for relationships mean
something not cheating or like getting
faced and like punching your friend like
those sorts of things that's not doing
that is meaningful but getting an award
is like weird it's weird
it's not a really a measure of success
in my life
rule number two ignore the critics
reading all the reviews everyone really
reviews I don't read them I've got I
don't even read the good ones because
you know because I get coal because I
met Chrissie Hynde once at Top of the
Pops like about eight years ago when I
had that once I had a hit that was
called taken for granted when I was an
urban artist and and she said to me
whatever you do don't you read reviews
or articles about yeah she said if you
believe the good you'll believe the bad
and there will be bad so I just thought
that's a good point and she's right
every time I've accidentally read one I
felt like rule number three create
greatness so that we might see her
creative process at work SIA took us
downstairs for a session with pianist
and collaborator Chris pray as we
watched and listened SIA began to
fashion a pop melody right there on the
spot
[Applause]
[Music]
so then that's all we would do that was
meant to commit my copy of that nice
work
I'm and then have like Rihanna cut it
next week how fast the words come to you
how much do you tweak them after you're
right I don't take them at all ready
don't have my any word fit I'm gonna
live like tomorrow doesn't exist like
chandelier an exist so if you bend them
in certain white the distinctive work
the repetition of a strong concept it's
how these two came up with Brittany's
sit it's perfume oh I don't even know
her know the woods here's the thing you
know we write these songs in like 40
minutes and then we just send them to
somebody and then we never really refer
back to them ever again SIA has spent
the last few years becoming one of pops
most successful songwriters her resume
is a whose huge of music superstars
Rihanna's diamonds Flo Rida's Wild Ones
[Music]
how long did it take you to write
titanium it was like around for 40
minutes I think and then maybe half an
hour to record the vocals that's amazing
rule number four have the right
intentions I don't reckon you have to be
beautiful to succeed in this industry
like beautiful-looking I think your
intention has to be in the right place
Scott from Nashville says what's the
message behind the video for alive oh no
message just was like thinking what's
another great thing I can do for like
the little kids that watch videos and
like something that's not hyper sexual
and that's kind of strong and shows
strength and discipline and and I what I
liked about making the videos with
Maddie was that it showed little kids
new ways to express themselves that
weren't already established it just sort
of felt like it's free free to be a
weirdo you know and I liked that and um
and so in this time I wanted to do more
representing of like young girls as
strong and disciplined and that was
really my when I found her online that
was really my my impetus was to just
share more images of strong girls that
was kind of it I'm gonna do strong boys
too soon
rule number five is play to your
strengths I'm a bad actor I realize now
that I've had to try make music videos
directing is much easier it's way fun
it's super challenging and I really
enjoy it but yeah acting I'm bad at I
feel like I think I'm a pretty good
director not great but pretty good I
think sometimes I come up with a good
idea and I mean the brief me one I
thought
a good idea that two and a half thousand
Polaroids like a flipbook
I think that was a good idea I've got
some more good ideas that I'd need to
make but that I don't actually have time
or energy to make yet so now I'm letting
other people make my music videos
because I found people who I trust rule
number six my personal favorite never
complained we were talking a little bit
earlier on about when this records
coming out first of all we should say
it's called some people have real
problems yeah anybody in particular that
that refers to well I was just saying
that you know like I'm pretty privileged
and I have to just try and make sure
that I'm responsible and I make sure
that I don't like start complaining
about things like rich people's problems
like you know the cleaner missed a spot
luxury problems yeah as we like to call
them that sort of thing because you know
there are people who don't have any legs
or or you know or you know whatever you
know they don't have any food of course
and so you were just relating to the
fact that you're very like we were
complaining during that any of the
recording process we if anyone would
complain the running gag was yeah well
some people have real problems exactly
we're in a studio making music yeah rule
number seven don't care what people
think
depress your compared to a lot of female
artists oh yeah give their list I wrote
something I can tell you who I know tell
me who I was anyway that's nice I love
her voice she's one of my favorite
voices that's flattering do you see that
as a compliment that you have or maybe
you want to be your own personality I
don't care I'm not I don't care about
how people what people think about me
out there unless they think I mean or
something but I don't carefully I think
I'm like someone else because I know I'm
not I'm a total weirdo and I'm not
selling a like a dream I'm not selling
like Fame like it's some sort of
fantastic thing I'm just trying to sell
music and get on with my real life and
I'm always flattered when people compare
me to other pop stars because they've
made loads of money that means oh well I
rule number eight understand your
clients is also the case when you for
example write for all the artists like
Christina Aguilera channeling well I do
it like an interview with them first
like a therapy session so for an hour or
so I well in her case I was like is
there anything that's upsetting you
because they ask me for ballads so I was
like is there anything you okay is there
anything that's upsetting you at all and
I was like you know can you tell me a
bit a little bit about what's happening
right now in your life and so she did
and so we wrote songs about that so she
went and fed Max and then I would start
a skeleton based on what she'd said and
she would come back like shift things
around or say I don't like that word I
like this word or how about this phrase
or what about this melody if I do this
here and we build it around that sort of
therapy session so I try and channel
them when I'm doing the song writing
rule number nine take care of yourself
years ago when SIA was Maddie's age
family friend Colin Hay from the Ozzy
band men at work he's reduced her to
Stevie Wonder he said I hope you're
happy and successful in everything you
do are you yeah can you believe it i I
do have I do spend a lot of time like
pinching myself I I have to say it's
been pretty amazing I might cry it's
been really amazing the last couple of
years of just being since I made the
decision to just take care of my own
sanity and serenity and stuff my life's
just improved so much and I'm honestly
surprised that things are working out so
well for me and rule number ten the last
one before the bonus clips is perform
amazingly
Oh
like it
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
with the share you think your
by our wave I you sure
[Music]
[Music]
now got some special SIA bonus clips for
you but before that my question of the
day relates to rule number six never
complain I want to know the people in
your life what is the number one
complaint that they have but leave it
down the comments below I'm really
curious to find out thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clips
even with all your success why do you
still shy away from the limelight from
Fame
well that's unpleasant you know if it
makes me feel a hunted or I don't know
it's just like it but my friends the
world with me the other day when the
paps were at the airport and it was like
they all got diarrhea and I had to
explain that it was like you go into
fight or flight work it's like you're
prey and they're the predator and you're
being hunted and it's I mean you know
you would you like to spend your life
feeling like prey probably not job so
yeah that's really all it is it's just
like wanting to have a regular life just
like a regular person and still be able
to make music and sing and stuff but
without having to sacrifice just having
a regular life when my dad lived at home
he was there until I was about 10 or 11
and he was a musician he bought me a
cassette player and what I used to do
with it is I used to just record
portions of songs so like I liked that
beat on the doors record that goes den
and Lennon oh no no no no no no no no no
no
so what I would do is I would just take
that part and I would make a 30-minute
cassette with just that part of the song
on it and then I remember another song I
did it with was um Chrissie Hynde don't
get me wrong that bit Wow
which I still can't do she can get every
note but I don't do that the attention
that you were getting after the last
album went six feet under one and put
that song at the end of the the series
and all of a sudden from not being known
here in the States everybody's like
who's who's that girl who's who sang
that song a nice nice bit of a tension
right the album finally came out in the
States because until then the last one
hadn't even come out here yeah I often
say that that resuscitated my career
which is you know kind of ironic when I
was flopping that everybody died in the
TV show yeah you were resuscitated yes I
thought it was funny so I'm imagining
that that gave you a profile that you
know up until then here in the states
you could have only dreamed of yeah
totally it was amazing it was magic
pants because I was considering going
into like dog like rescuing or making
jewelry yeah like squeezing out pups you
know that thing like just you know
settling down right exactly and so you
got the opportunity to make another work
I did and also I realize you don't
actually need to be successful to make
music and put out music these days cuz
the record companies are kind of
becoming obsolete ways your standard
Apple at the core is core value
is that movie that people have passion
and change the way people not one drop
of myself work depends on your it's
supposed to me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details